الفلسطينيون في مخيم جنين جثامين عددا من
الشهداء الذين قتلوا برصاص الجيش
الاسرائيلي خلال عمليه اقتحام للمخيم
تخللتها اشتباكات عنيفه مع مقاتلينا من
فصائل المقاومه وعلى اثر هذا التصعيد عقدت
حكومه نتنياهو ومشاورات امنيه تحسبا
لتصعيد محتمل بينما توعدت فصائل المقاومه
تل ابيب بدفع الثمن واشنطن فدعت في وقفه
ما وصفته بدوامه العنف
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هناك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مساره كيف نفسر تصعيد الحكومه
الاسرائيليه اليمنيه حملتها ضد
الفلسطينيين في الضفه الغربيه مباشره بعد
لقاءات في المنطقه شاملات زياره مستشار
الامن القومي الامريكي سولبا لتل ابيب
والالقاء نتنياهو بالعهد الاردني تابعتها
مباشره زياره الملك عبد الله لدوله قطر
والى اي حد يعكس السلوك الاسرائيلي ازمه
سياسيه داخليه يحاول نتنياهو تصديرها الى
الضفه الغربيه في ظل تصاعد الاحتجاجات ضد
السياسات حكومته التي يقودها اليمين
المتطرف وكيف سيتعامل الفلسطيني
مع الوضع الراهن وكيف نقرا المواقف
الامريكيه والدوليه ازاله الصيد
الاسرائيلي وماذا تملكه من ادوات للضغط
وتهدئه الاوضاع والحلوله دون انزلاقها الى
مواجهه بالضفه في انشغالي واشنطن بالحرب
الاوكرانيه والتحديات الصينيه
[موسيقى]
اذا اردت اليقين فيما يتعلق بدياتي
والجندت حكومه نتنياهوف عليك بممارسات
الجيش الاحتلال على الارض وليس ما قد يصدر
من تصريحات هنا او هناك ذاك ما يقوله حال
الفلسطينيين وهم يشيعون شهدائهم الذين
قضوا في اقتحام القوات الاسرائيليه مخيمه
جنين ساعات بعد لقاء لنتنياهو بالعهد
الاردني استمع فيه للملك عبد الله وهو
يدعو للتهدئه وتجنب التصعيد الامريكي
في ابرز ردود الفعل الفلسطينيه اعلانات
الرئاسه الفلسطينيه وقفت تعاون الامني مع
اسرائيل
مشددتان على ان تل ابيب ترتكب جرائمها بحق
الشعب الفلسطيني مستفيده من عجز وصلت
المجتمع الدولي من جهتها اكدت حركه الجهاد
الاسلامي ان تصعيد الاسرائيلي سيفتح الباب
امام معركه مفتوحه يتحمل الاحتلال
مسؤوليته تابعتها حركه حماس اكدت ان
الاحتلال سيدفع ثمن ما وصفتته بالمجزره
التي نفذها في جنين ومخيمها عربيا نددت
دول عربيه عديده بمقترفته القوات
الاسرائيليه بحق الفلسطينيين بينها قطر
التي اكدت ان الافلات من العقاب وما يشجع
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على ارتكاب ما يقوم
به في جنين وغيرها امام الامم المتحده
التي حذرت من العواقب السلبيه لوقف
التنسيق الامني مع اسرائيل اكدت انه من
الاهميه بمكان الحد من التوترات والعنف
على الفور لمنع المزيد من الخسائر في
الارواح وعلى مشاري في زياره قادمه لوزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه انطونيو بلينكن الى
المنطقه قالت الخارجيه الامريكيه ان
بلانكين سيدعوا خلال جولته في المنطقه الى
ضروره وضعته
[موسيقى]
مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنى طاهر المصري رئيس
الوزراء الاردنيه السابق وعدى شديد الباحث
المتخصص في الشان الاسرائيلي مرحبا بكما
سيطاهر المصري اذا حكومه ائتلاف اليمين
الاكثر تشددا ولكن تصعيد جاء ايضا بعد
زياره سوليفان الى اسرائيل وايضا زياره
نتنياهو ولقائه بالعهده الاردني وزياره
الملك عبد الله ايضا الى قطر كيف نفهم هذا
التصعيد في ظل هذه اللقاءات
زياره نتنياهو الى عمان بهذا التوقيت
والاعتداء على جنين في في اليوم التالي هو
خطوه لئيمه وهدف لئيم تريد ان تشعر بان
الاردن له موقف معلن وموقف
هذا
هو الهدف الذي قصده ونحن نعلم ان
الحكومه الجديده خطره وانها لها برامج
واضحه
ومهمه في موضوع ضم الضفه الغربيه اليها
انا بعتقد انه هذا هذه المجزره وهذه زياره
في هذا الوقت هي بدايه تنفيذ ااه ضم الظفر
الفلسطينيه الى ال- ال- اسرائيل
وسنرى همم
اكثر من ذلك في المستقبل العالم مش سائل
العالم همم مضمر الشر لفلسطينيين والعرب
وباعرف انه بتكلم بصفه يعني شديده اللهجه
لكن تعب المنطقه
من كل هذه
التاخيرات لسه همم جايب وزير خارجيه همم
الولايات المتحده بده يشوف شو صار مع ان
همم سنوات ما معروف شو صار وما في همم
امور واضحه جدا
همم
كيف تنظر الى ما جرى اليوم على ضوء انها
حكومه في النهايه هي حكومه اليمين اكثر
تشددا
وعندما اتت اتت بهذه المعلنه
مساء الخير لكي استاذه سلمى والضيفك
الاستاذ طاهر من عمان ولي مشاهديكم
لا شك انه
كان واضح قبل تشكيل هذه الحكومه انا
المنطقه ذاهبه بهذا الاتجاه الي سبب بسيط
انه هذه الحكومه ولا اول مره بتاريخ
حكومات اسرائيل منذ نكمه شعب نعم 75 عام
تضم جماعه
الكهانيين في اسرائيل اولئك الذين لا
يعترفون اصلا
بوجود شعب فلسطيني
وبالمناسبه هذه الحكومه لم تعد تداعياتها
فقط خطيره على الشعب الفلسطيني وقضيته
الوطنيه وعلى فلسطين انما على المنطق
والاردن هاي المجموعه التي
تشكل المركب الاهم للحكومه جماعه
الصهيونيه الدينيه بزعامه بتسل
ايلسموتريتش وعد جماعه العظمه اليهوديه
بزعامه اطامات بنجرير يعتبرون ان الحركه
الصهيونيه قبل 100 عام اخطات مع الانتداب
البريطاني حين قبله بما يسمى اخراج الضفه
الشرقيه من
اقامه دوله اسرائيل وان الاردن يجوز جزء
من ما يسمى ارض اسرائيل وسمعنا
بالفتره الماضيه الكثير من الاصوات التي
صدرت من من تيارات الصهيونيه الدينيه
بضروره ما يسمى اعاده ضم الاردن يعني لم
يعد الحديث اليوم بالنقاش الاسرائيلي
الداخلي على وجهه نظر شارون والوقود ان
الاردن هو الوطن البديل للشعب الفلسطيني
اليوم الحديث ان الاردن هو جزء من ما يسمى
دوله اسرائيل بالتالي نحن امام حكومه تضم
تيار ديني قومي اا يؤمن ب ب بذلك وبالتالي
بات مقتنعا و ولا يعبر يعني ولا يخجل
بالتعبير عن فلسفه اتجاه اليات التنفيذ
لتحقيق هذا المشروع اللي وصفها بثلاث
خطوات اما الرحيل والهجره التوعيه لانك
فلسطينيه او ان نكون عبيدا او في حال رفض
من الهجره وان تكون عبيد ان نلقى مصيرنا
بالقتل والبطشي والارهاب والاجرام واعتقد
انه
اليوم كل الخريطه الفلسطينيه
مستهدفه عالحكومه الحاليه ان لم تقم فقط
باجراءات الضم اتباع الضفه الغربيه
للاداره المدنيه الاسرائيليه واتباع
الاداره المدنيه لوزير ضمن حكومه اسرائيل
وليس للجيش هو ضم الضفه الغربيه بشكل فعلي
بعيدا عن اجراءات تمريرها بالكنيسه لتلاشي
اي رده فعل امريكيه او اوروبيه من الممكن
ان تحرج نتنياهو تحديدا في في هذه الحكومه
انه في برنامج لم يفرق ما بين الجليل
ساعود اليك سيد عادل شديد نسال اكثر عن
حدود هذا تصعيد ولكن اريد ان افهم من
سيطاهر المصري عندما تحدث بان الاجند
الواضحه هي عمليه الضم لهذه الحكومه ضمن
الضفه الغربيه
بناء على ما جرى اليوم والخطوات التصعيديه
التي شاهدناها منذ بدايه وصول هذه الحكومه
اقتحامات للمدن الفلسطينيه اقتحام للاقصى
هدم البيوت قتل الشهداء شبه اليومي
بالاضافه الى الاعلانات على الاستيطان كيف
برايك ستترجم هذه الحكومه هذه النوايا
التي باتت واضحه
هي الاعلانات واضحه جدا
ونوايا الحكومه ذكرتيها وكلنا نعرفها
تقوم بعمل الماء ما تعتقد انه هو سياستها
بشكل يعني واضح وبدون وبدون خجل في
الموضوع لذلك انا بعتقد انه
يعني اسرائيل مساله اسرائيل اذا الان بعد
كل هالكلام اذا الان ناطق الرسمي
بقول انه التنسيق الامني
يعني
مش لازم يحدث طب قتلته كلها الناس وعمالكم
تاخذوا الاراضي وما ما ما ما ما ما ما
تزعل هذا الكلام انا باعتقد انه لازم كل
الاجراءات اللي طلبتها اللي
اه
السلطه يجب ان تاتا تتم الى الى حدها
الاقصى وان نذهب الى كل الاماكن والان
اصبح اا بعلنا وفش نقاش فيها انه اسرائيل
بدها تضم كل فلسطين وبدها تعتدي على
الاردن
والعالم عم بتفرج يعني ما فيش ما فيش اي
ضابط ما فيش احتجاج على على اسرائيل انا
بعتقد انه بالتداعيات هذا الامر اذا
استمرت كما هي اسمحي لي اقول لك همم سلمى
انه في همم الان نتجه نحو صراع الحضارات
همم بعد اوكرانيا وبعد الدوري الاوروبي
وبعد التصرف الامريكي والعدوان الاسرائيلي
لابد انه يحدث شيء من هذا القبيل خصوصا
انه الصين والهند وهمم دول اخرى كبيره
ليست منضمه الى هذا الى هذه
الحضاره همم اللي همم ينتمون اليها
الحرب
المشكله تتخذ ذلك الاتجاه اللي انا اعتقد
انه سوف يتوسع ولذلك انا احذر بانه هذا
هذه التصرفات سوف تغير مصير المنطقه
والعالم لانه اذا تحولنا الى
صراع حراره حضارات الله يستر ههه
التصعيد والعمليات الامنيه هي لطالما كانت
جيدا اسرائيل مهما اختلفت الحكومات ولكن
همم هل ترى ايضا بان بل داخل الاسرائيلي
حاله النزاع السياسي والمجتمع داخل
اسرائيل ايضا كان عاملا محفزا يضاف الى
البعد الامني الدائم لدى كل الحكومات
الاسرائيليه
يعني من تاكيد انه هذا التصعيد اللي لا
يمكن فصله عن التصعيد اللي سبق الانتخابات
الاخيره في اسرائيل وتشكيل هذه الحكومه
المتطرفين انه هنالك في ثلاث متغيرات ادت
الى هذا الواقع التصعيدي واللي همم
سيرافقنا بالمرحله القادمه وسيتاعد اكثر
بكثير المتغير الاول وهو تشكيله وتركيبه
الحكومه الاسرائيليه الحاليه انضمام جماعه
تمر بني كبير
ومعوز واستراك وكل هذه المجموعه واللي
بيشكله قوه اليوم هم اللي بيشكلوا الدوله
العميقه وبالمناسبه همم موضوع التصعيد
جنين سمكه همم اقتحام بالامس عشرات ضباط
وقيادات بشرطه الاحتلال الى المسجد الاقصى
وقبه الصخره اللي حدث بعد ساعات من زياره
نتنياهو
والرئيس الشباب ورئيس ما يسمى مجلس الامن
القومي في التابع لرئاسه الحكومه في
اسرائيل بالتالي هاي الحكومه هذا مشروحه
المتغير الثاني كما تحدثت هي المظاهرات
اللي اخذ التصاعد في اسرائيل ضد سياسه
الحكومه الداخليه ولكي نكون واضحين انه
الاغلبيه الساحقه من الذين يشاركون
وينزرون للشوارع في اسرائيل ضد برنامج
حكومه نتنياهو هم ضد برنامج داخل فيما
يتعلق باقصاع محكمه العدل العليا والجهاز
القضائي واحلال قوانين الدينيه وشرائع
دينيه محل القانون الاسرائيلي و و و و
علاقه الدين بالدولي تحديدا والحريات
الفرديه وبالتالي استمرارها بالتاكيد
سيزعجه
وقد يشكل خطر وقد يهدي التصدعات وقدد
تتطور الامور الى اضرابات وبالتالي
افضل الطرق لثانيهاه للهروب باتجاه الامام
وتصعيد دموي مع الفلسطينيين بالاقصى
باللقب بالجليل بالضبط مع غازي ثم المتغير
الثالث والذي لا يقل الاهميه ايضا وهو
وجود هذه الظاهره الجديده كتيبه جنين عرين
الاسود عائل المجموعات التي تشكلت ونقلت
في المواجهه الشعبيه من القاء حجاره
وزجاجات حارقه الى اطلاق رصاص وقنابل
والغام وهذا باتيكل مصدر ازمه قوي
للمنظومه الامنيه والسياسيه في اسرائيل
من انتقاله وانتشاره الى باقي محافظه
الضفه
همم الى اين تسير الاوضاع في المنطقه
مستقبلا في ضوء المؤشرات الدبلوماسيه
وايضا ما تقوم به اسرائيل على الارض من
ممارسات وسائل الاعلام اسرائيليه قالت ان
الجيش الاحتلال رفع حاله التاهب على حدود
قطاع غزه في عقاب العمليه في جنين وقالت
هيئه البث الاسرائيليه ان رئيس الحكومه
بنيامين نتنياهو يعقدوا مشاورات امنيه
تحسبا لتصعيد المحتمل سيد عادل شديد همم
الحركات الجهات قالت بان هذه العمليه في
هذا اليوم لن تمر دون رد همم برايك كيف
ستكون طبيعه وحدود الرد من قبل الفصائل
همم خاصه حركه الجهاد على ضوء احاديث
وتوجهات من احتمال وقوع انتفاضه في الضفه
بين جنين ونابلس
يعني بالتاكيد انه مجزره جنين اليوم
عما قد حاله الاحتقان والغضب الجماهيري
وبات الراي العام الفلسطيني والشارع
الفلسطيني اكثر احتضانا ودعمنا للمشروع
المقاومه والعمليات وبالتالي
عمليات اليوم وضعت الجهاد الاسلامي كما
حماس كما السلطه كما الجميع في موقف محرج
تماما وباقي الشارع الفلسطيني ايضا يضغط
كثيرا على السلطه على فتاه على حماس على
الجهاد للرد بشكل يرتقي ويناسب هذا
التصعيد الاجرامي وهذه الدماء الكثيره
التي سالت اليوم في جنين بالتالي كل
الخيارات والده انه احتماليه حدوث عمليات
بالضفه تستهدف الجنود والمستوطنين باتت
وارد جدا بكل الضفه ممكن عمليات بالداخل
سنعود يعني للمشاهده عوده العمليات
الاستشهاديه وفي لحظه مع
انت تطور الامور الى مواجهه ما مع غزه
واعتقد انه بحينه ستكون يعني سيكون
نتنياهم قد نجح على الاقل في في في اخماد
وفي همم اضعاف
الحركه الجماهيريه ضده بالداخل لانه
بالشارع الاسرائيلي لا يمكن اعطاء شرعيه
ومظاهره ضد الحكومه وفي مواجهه مع
الفلسطينيين سيد طاهر برايك هل الحكومه
الامريكيه وزياره بلينكن القادمه للمنطقه
ستلجم هذا التصعيد والاندفاع من قبل
الحكومه كي يعني لا تشهد الولايات المتحده
واشنطن انشغالا بملفات تزيد عليها حملا
همم وهي همم يعني منشغله اساسا بالملف
الاوكراني وايضا البعد الصيني
مؤقتا سوف نظهر بعض التاثير الامريكي على
هذه الحكومه ولكن
سيكون ذلك مؤقت واعتقد ان
نتنياه يريد ان ينهي كل هذه الملفات
المنهجيه موجوده امامه قبل
حدوث مشاكل اخرى في اوكرانيا في المشهد
الداخلي نعم لن يتوقفوا وكلامهم للزعماء
ولخبراء الذين يقابلونهم لا يعني شيئا
كثير لانه
سفير هو اقوى من رئيس الوزراء ونحن نعرف
ما هي نوايا وسيستمر في هذا ربما يظهر
يشائر الامريكان ولكن
كل مظهر فاضي يعني ما اله قيمه سيد عادل
شديد برايك همم كيف ستكون عمليه همم تبعات
هذه العمليه والردود في ضوء بهذه النار
التي تغلي همم تحت همم اكثر من منطقه
فلسطينيه القدس نابلس وجنين وخاصه بان
ايضا السلطه الفلسطينيه تحدث
يعني واضح تماما ان الامم المتحده
والاداره الامريكيه واطراف اوروبيه وحتى
اطراف عربيه ليست معنيه بهذا الخطوه معنيه
ببقاء الى حد ما حاله الاستقرار الهش وعدم
تصاعد الامور بالمناسبه زيارات الامريكيه
ليست مرتبطه بشكل كبير وجدي في الموضوع
الفلسطيني هم ليسوا ماليين بذهاب التصعيد
الاسرائيلي الى صفوف اعلى من السقف الحالي
لكي لا تنفجر الامور اكثر ولكن التركيز
الامريكي اليوم الاوروبي على اسرائيل
بفرمت ووضع كوابح للاندفاع الديني باتجاه
فرض دوله الشريعه لانه القراءه الامريكيه
وحتى قراءه الاكاديميين الاسرائيليين انه
فرض دوله شريعه يهوديه في اسرائيل
همم الشق الوطني من الحركه الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه وقد ينظر بمرحله ما بعد منظمه
التحرير
ودعم الاسلام السياسي انتشار هذا الموضوع
بمنطقه الشرق الاوسط وهذا ما لا تريده لا
الاداره الامريكيه ولا الاوروبيين ولا قوه
الان بخصوص سؤالك الى اين تذهب الامور
واضح انه عمليه جنين اليوم لن تكون
العمليه الاسرائيلي الاولى سيذبحها شكرا
وستكون هنالك ردود فلسطينيه بالتاكيد ولكن
تبقى الحاله الفلسطينيه الغير منتجه تماما
تبقى تشكل عائق امام
شكرا لك عادل شديد
شكرا لكم
يا طاهر المصري رئيس الوزراء الاردني
برنامج ما وراء الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]